- Well, Tim, in 1883,
Faith plays your wife.
So that must have been a stretch.
And Isabel plays your daughter.
Does she fit in, right
in with your family?
I feel like literally
I'm looking at a girl
that could have come from y'all. So.
(audience laughs)
- When we first saw Izzy, when we walked,
at the first day at cowboy camp,
when we walked in, I mean, of
course she's just beautiful,
and sweet, and so poised, and so mature.
But when we first saw her, we went,
right away, we thought,
"My gosh, she looks like
she could be our daughter."
I mean, it was just perfect casting.
And then, and the more we got to know her,
the sweeter she got, and the
more we grew to love her,
and respected her.
And she's just a,
she's incredible.
She just shines in this show,
and anybody who knows her
and was around her on set,
knows that she shines in
person as well in real life.
- [Kelly] Oh that's so...
- I miss you Tim.
- That's so sweet.
(audience applauds)
What I have to ask, like, what is,
first of all, we're gonna
get back to cowboy camp.
That sounds like City Slickers, the movie,
and I'm very excited about it.
(Izzy laughs)
I love that film, all of them,
but what was it like having Tim and Faith
as parents in a show?
That's crazy.
- I'm, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Kind of incredible.
I mean, Tim knows this already,
so this isn't a big shock to him,
but I didn't know who they were.
- Wait, what?
- Yes. I didn't know that they were big.
- What rock did you live under?
Why? What?
- [Isabel] I know.
- You're young. I guess you're like 21?
- Yes. But my, like my,
I just, I don't know.
I hide away.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- [Isabel] I'm a hermit.
- You're so lucky though.
You have all this music
to catch up on. Okay.
- [Isabel] I know.
- Yes.
- And I'm very excited to,
but to me, I just got to get to know them
as just human, they're just,
you know, human beings.
So there was a blank slate
and, my goodness, are they
just the loveliest people
I think I've ever met.
I immediately fell in love with them.
And it was so genuine.
And, I mean, Faith Hill is
one of the kindest people
I think I've ever met in my
life, and she's a goofball.
- [Kelly] And she's funny.
- She's such a goofball. Oh my goodness.
She makes animal noises,
weird animal noises.
- Wait, what?
- Yes. She's so gifted at it,
too. Okay, I'll stop there.
I don't wanna do one.
- Next time I have Faith on
that will be what I ask her.
Give me an animal noise.
- Do like (oinks)
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Oh, I did a little bit of it.
I didn't know if that was gonna work.
- [Kelly] I love it. I love it.